[Music]  all right people settle in relax  give me a call  this is on the line  are you ready I'm always ready we're  expecting your calls talk to Elvis live  on air and tell him about all of your  issues and problems  it's a radio host  [Music]  okay we got Gary on the line what to say  you Gary  [Applause]  foreign  belong to someone you know no it belongs  to somebody not very nice and I'm I'm  gonna take out his whole family  Gary what was that I'm breaking into the  top hey Gary stop wait come on why hurt  his family I mean they're innocent  you're better than that Gary tell me  calmly  where exactly are you  your house  of your life see I created a game and I  think you're gonna love it  [Music]  still end well  I don't want it to end well  I don't want to die here  [Music]  what if we don't want to die we gotta  fight well that won't be easy  now I want you to jump  you tell us the truth we're all  listening show yourself your slippery  Sonoma  [Music]